avec ses 8 115 kilomètres carrés le parc
naturel de la vallée de chevreuse est un
grand espace regroupant notamment la
vallée de chevreuse et la forêt de
rambouillet pour en parler nous voler
nos avants bonjour bonjour vous êtes
guide de park et je suppose que vous
connaissez dans les environs énormément
de balades et de promenades et de
randonnées à faire oui exactement on a
vraiment beaucoup de chance d'être sur
ce territoire très varié qui nous permet
d'avoir beaucoup de randonnées à faire
mais en termes de faune et flore on est
en plein hiver qu'est ce qu'on peut voir
en ce moment alors même en plein hiver à
la forêt est riche de plein d'animaux on
a des oiseaux qui viennent passer
l'hiver ici notamment les terrains des
aulnes ou encore sur sur les étangs on
peut observer des oiseaux qui sont assez
rares donc là si je veux partir faire
une petite promenade c'est l'hiver j'ai
pas envie d'avoir froid trop longtemps
mais quand même pour me rafraîchir
qu'est ce que voit ce que je vais d'ici
alors au départ
du petit moulin du parking du petit
moulin au niveau du rue des veaux c'est
vrai qu'il y à une grande diversité de
bagdad on peut faire des petites boucles
de 2 km pour ceux qui ne veulent pas
marcher longtemps jusqu'à plusieurs
dizaines de kilomètres sans problème est
peut-être un petit site aussi de
patrimoine bâti qu'on peut voir dans les
environs alors il ya la balade des
moulins qui propose au long du rue des
veaux six moulins à découvrir et on peut
également monter jusque dans la carrière
des maréchaux pour voir les traces du
passé merci beaucoup cela une boivin et
nous on va s'empresser d'aller marcher
un peu se promener un peu et découvrir
les plantes sauvages comestibles avec
stéphane loriot
donc nous sommes avec stéphane loriot
animateurs patrimoine au pm et bonjour
bonjour est ce que le pnr est riche en
terme de plantes sauvages comestibles
par définition oui ce n'est pas un
endroit unique tente de consoler
combustible mais l'endroit s'y prêtent
davantage évidemment on va aller en
découvrir quelques-unes vous pouvez nous
en montrer à proximité là
[Musique]
donc là nous avons par exemple la stèle
l'aria médias
avec ses petites fleurs blanches en
forme des toiles caractéristiques qui
peuvent faire trois quatre cinq cycles
dans l'année c'est une plante annuelle
qui résiste au froid les gelées sont
faibles et vous avez ici donc ce premier
cycle de cette plante qui en préparation
froide constitue l'une des meilleures
salhab en préparations froides d'europe
alors vous avez si de nouveaux cette
belle rose est de cardamines pire suite
op
[Musique]
voilà déjà ce goût piquant aux
caractéristiques amer parce que beaucoup
plantes sauvages ou cette amertume que
l'on recherche et la chaude ou froide la
préparation vraiment intéressant que
vous en mettez 10 15% dans vos
préparations et vous avez un condiment
qui se rapprochent j'ai envie de vous
dire de la moutarde ou du climat ok moi
ça bah on dirait un
salad avec un petit bout de la pression
de terrain voilà c'est la même famille
cela tombe bien ok oui aille en arrière
goût qui pique un peu et voilà et
c'était un goût amer et qui picote
devait rester en bouche un petit quart
d'heure d'accord et c'est souvent le cas
avec les personnages et les plantes
sauvages sont moins regardante que nos
plantes cultivées elles sont mus la plus
rustique mais qui dit rusticité dit
notamment complémentaires alimente a
commandé en termes de literie mans les
plantes sauvages sont deux autres plus
nourrissante que nos plantes cultivées
et c'est ce qui fait leur force dans les
temps en futur elles ont leur place pour
complémenter notre alimentation qui
n'est pas au meilleur filtre au fil des
années
[Musique]
là vous avez un sol humide tromper toute
l'année vous avez la cardamine amer la
cardamine à caméra qui a qui poussent
dans les sols trempé et là en termes de
saveur piquant poivre et pimentée c'est
vraiment je pense que c'est ce qui a
mieux c'est ce que nous avons de mieux
en europe tout simplement
elle est succulent amer évidemment
pimenté poivrée com com comme rarement
et qui reste en bouche excréments
humains voyage l'attak qui piquent
énormément enfin expliqué normalement ça
dépend de sa sensibilité mais qui met
mais ça c'est pendant ces web et là vous
pouvez fabriquer des sauces froides ou
chaudes vraiment ça c'est plus pour
faire des sauces c'est une plante
cousine qui relèvent le goût dans un
plat sa relève la plupart des drive mais
sauf que le goût des rares est différent
par contre le deuxième bout à bas le
deuxième ça c est le premier on dirait
qu'on prend un petit peu de moutarde
ouais quand même il ya un petit côté
moutarde de dijon premier prix
alors discrètement mais tout de même
vous avez ici le gaillet et gratuit donc
cette plante en dessous pour velouté
vraiment vraiment intéressante depuis en
salade hachez finement aux ménages
[Musique]
voilà donc vous avez maintenant quelques
idées de promenades ici dans le parc
naturel de la vallée de chevreuse elles
peuvent faire plusieurs kilomètres ou
même quelques centaines de mètres si
vous souhaitez vous arrêter sur les
plantes sauvages comestibles
il suffit de venir au parc seul ou même
accompagné d'un guide pour avoir plus de
précision avec eux
[Musique]